what is a muggle is it something that
holds your butterbeer
[Music]
Harry Potter is a sorcerer I think he's
short he's got a very hairy friend I
know there's also like a bad guy in it
some bald dude with no nose paul de mort
you know why he lost his nose to harry
ron because this is this brett the girl
i don't now
Lizzie they like fly around on
broomsticks right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I walked into Diagon Alley it was
like the New York of the Wizarding World
of Harry Potter I went to Ollivanders
and they matched me with a wand Colm to
trade on the tip of the wand and say
Lumos Lumos yeah the one has to be like
perfect for you because if it doesn't
fit it's not gonna work
we're at quality cottage supplies and we
just found out what Quidditch was
basically Quidditch is probably like a
soccer floating site here like a wizard
soccer inter stranger but take heed of
what awaits the sin of greed sounds like
we're gonna do something at Gringotts
that we shouldn't be doing and I think
we're gonna get in a lot of trouble for
it it was really fun
we meant Baltimore we saw Voldemort and
Santa's lemonade they did say that we
were muggles so I'm assuming muggles are
human we were right about the muggles
yeah metal Oh jinx I don't think you're
pointing at the metal Oh jinx metal Oh
jinx metal Oh jinx metal Oh James
you walk around the park and you find
these cool symbols on the ground that
tell you how to motion your wand
voila magic I think we've earned our
right to be Wizards now
we are in Hogsmeade I thought it was a
pig it is not a pig there's snow it's
like a little village and there's butter
beer oh that's gonna be good we are
trying the Bertie Botts every flavour
beans challenge and we're gonna try and
see how many flavors we can guess tastes
like blueberry this is yellow and it has
like brown specks on it I regret my
decision I don't know it tastes like a
toe it's like speckled with red and blue
and yellow I'm okay with my human food
[Music]
we went on Harry Potter and The
Forbidden Journey the paintings were
talking to us we got to like be infront
of a dragon it's pretty cool we finally
made it to the Quidditch game that which
what yeah that was a lot of fun it was
like going on a journey with Harry
Potter Harry Potter is a wizard his two
best friends are Ron and Hermione
Gryffindor Slytherin hufflepuff and
Ravenclaw it's fair to say but I
actually feel at home here I kind of
want to like actually be a wizard and
live in Auburn new most
[Music]